hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play slender
prison I said that I was gonna get back
in here because I think I think I have a
decent strategy with which how to deal
with slender now I know that this is
actually one of the hardest ones but the
strategist in me really really really
wants to be this guy but it's very very
tough I think I am correct in thinking
that the way to beat in Harry maloha the
way to beat abuse he's more of a weeping
angels style you've got to keep an eye
on him but only selectively got to be
very careful about how you do it's a
balancing yeah you can't get caught out
and open always you got it's like and
someone said something about the the
light turns green occasionally when when
he's near by which would make sense
considering that why else would they put
a keychain in just it kind of makes
sense now there's a keychain here
whereas there was no before there was no
visible source of the light I'm getting
a little lag here I don't know why sorry
about that
if you'll go away soon enough we done
done with a lag no oh no not really okay
I see oh it is all right nothing so far
okay oh come on stop lagging I need to
beat slender
performance issues a sighs very quiet
I'm actually checking in these cells
because I don't know how many page
location or photo locations there are in
this particular level but I don't know
they might be back in some other spots
hopefully I'll be able to get some soon
that's really quiet
it's like unnerving ly quiet cuz I know
that he's a son of a [ __ ] okay okay if
he pops up I'm not gonna sprint
immediately I'm gonna flip around what's
in the light just in case it turns green
flip around and get my eye on once I got
a bead on him II can't move positive
with that boy I got him around a corner
ah see the light did turn a little green
okay so he can't move from there so
what's dealio
[Music]
all right so I get bad yes exactly that
is it that is it but my light's still
green okay just what doc green I think
the green one away
okay I gotta go in here okay this one
here all right this is where I've died
many times before and I'm still getting
a little lag I don't know why bad places
for a lag the light is not green mine is
not green all right all right all right
[Music]
watching that light all right okay I
mean other than this area I don't know
if the other page spawns are as
consistent as fives ha letter where is
he where is he where is he where is he
where's he flipped green in foot green
in foot green
it was green was green who's green who's
green okay
ha ha I thought I saw him turning green
it's bright green now it's bright
freakin green why where is he
Rosie Harry's let's see you okay
can she round the corner wait what was
that looks like a glow on the wall what
is that
no no I don't know something lighting up
on the wall she's still there no it's
gone okay
see my strategy is sound just got to get
him around corners that's why it's bad
to be caught in an open hallway because
if he's there you can't go anywhere else
he's just gonna get
okay as long as you got I'm around
something you're okay actually what I
didn't want to be caught in all right is
there no all right page in there
no okay there might have been I don't
know I know there's a page on the bed
somewhere but I'm and it's so easy to
get lost in this place ha like am I on
you
not today not tomorrow at the next day
[Music]
okay
again them backing up is bad
backing up means you running to slender
okay alright okay so once you get him
around a corner
turn the foot round Oh God
I was doing well at least I actually got
away
few times Harry Bell or everybody doing
with me Harry below
[Music]
let's go this way first all right so
just I wasn't paying attention to the
light either so it might have was that
oh there's a photo right here holy crap
I didn't know that I him the photo the
light might have been glowing green and
I didn't I wasn't paying attention so we
might have might have been a giveaway
that he was right behind me there nope
[Music]
it's always moved forward and don't be a
douche the good rules to live by always
move forward and don't be a douche cuz
being a dish needs to douchey lifestyle
and if you're a douche I'm gonna check
all of these cells now cuz in this cell
area it's not actually that dangerous
because I can get them around corners
and one done don't see anything I think
the area are needy goes in here for the
long haul or the the back home whatever
you want to call it I I don't have names
for these things I just noticed that the
wall texture is kind of kinda are creepy
I'm gonna go in here actually cut back
in left aha that's why two of eight
bring it on Slendy I'm scared of you
I scared a new one I scared it nothing
ever I'm the bravest I'm so great it's
unreal how great I am I am so great
oh just the best just the best best ever
was were ha ha ha not today cause you
round the corner I don't know if that's
actually a rule but it seems to be
working
yay life is good life good ah got you
around the corner Han flip-flop the old
switcheroo bah
ah oh no oh no oh no load it huh it's so
dark I don't want to go to the hallway
in the dark oh yeah the dark
oh god it's so dark no dirt moves' Oh
dick are you gonna do anything
donut like give me light Oh give me
light please I'm not moving I'm not
moving
ha I saw him tell us his arm reaching
through the wall there oh don't get here
don't give me here man that'd be a bad
place to get me
okay okay he's gonna pop up by me I
gotta I'll get around a corner too much
too much hallway I gotta get that place
first cuz if I get caught there I'm dead
no matter what I just kicked dude I just
can't deal with it I mean he's so
freakin quick when you're not looking at
him oh man it's like a catch-22 it's the
worst is freaking hard anyway Harry
Malloy
[Music]
in prison
I love me some prison favorite place to
leave
[Music]
I think wait wait no the quickest route
of that area is which way I'm not
entirely sure myself ah it's probably
gonna spell my doom here we go
cuz it's a right turn from here and then
it's a but is a long walk off of this
right turn and it wasn't one in there
okay no this way ah God see once again
I'm confused I think I know the right
way and then I don't know the right way
and then I'm all turned around and I'm
boned from here on out come on [ __ ]
man just you and me just you and me mano
a mano
what's up this way
[Music]
is something here
oh yeah these empty rooms I don't know
what they're here for but I'm going the
completely wrong way I know he's
checking these all right back in here
and then we're gonna go on a merry way
and then live happily ever after
I see them yeah I do I know I don't know
how much time I get from looking at him
I don't know I mean it's it's a
considerable amount I think they
increase the time just because of the
safety constraint that you need to look
at him or whatever but you know just not
know yup he sure good good good good
good not good but you know it's okay
[Music]
visitors is it does uh oh why why does
it keep slowing down like this seriously
why is it keep why does my game keep
slowing down like that and now it's dark
I don't want to be in the dark I don't
want to be here in the dark I don't want
to be here in the dark oh I don't want
to be here in the dark no no I don't
want to be here in the dark oh no you
gonna stand right here right here
there we go huh ah light how lovely
light and then no lag starts again it's
never done that before
never done that before I thought I had
more than two oh boy all right
I haven't been able to get more than
four if you're keeping track I'm not
maybe if I'd like skirt this edge and if
he pops up I'll be able to wrap him
around that corner oh no no no got my
eye on you Oh get through the door there
yeah yeah okay there's a lot of time
there's a lot of time to look at them
there's a surprising amount of time to
look at them all right I still get a
check there's two separate like
isolation rooms that need to be checked
I conquered that one hallway I think
that's the toughest part as long as you
get that out of the way you're pretty
much set I suppose where the heck does
this lead ah there's one of the
isolation rooms got it page photo thing
whatever you want to call it
[Music]
that doesn't lead anywhere let me go in
here and that's a long open hallway that
I don't want to be in ok these leads
back to these cells here which is good
because there's a lot of area to lose
him go around go around go around go
around ha ha [ __ ] that's what I thought
too tough for you ah what the hell I saw
that don't try to play trick on note you
know uh uh is lucky I don't have a chair
[Music]
uh-uh
man this is okay man this is
unbelievably hard man Wow there's got to
be a specific route that you have to run
that way you have to do it quick and get
it done and then I I swear this I don't
know why my game was lagging never done
that before I think like there was a bit
of lag as I tried to flip around there
but like still it wouldn't matter does
on a long hallway he would kill me
anyway so thank you all so much for
watching I'm sorry I'm doing terrible of
this one but I imagine everybody else is
too so I think the strategy is sound if
you want to try it yourself it works and
there's a lot more time to look at them
than you think there is so keep it up
guys let me know if one of you guys beat
it cuz ah I would love to know how to
beat this thing's anyway thank you all
so much for watching and as I'll click
the annotation for more videos that I've
done in as always I'll see you in the
next video bye bye